you're the first participant I'm filming
today for my new project it's called
write it forward basically you read a
note from a stranger who I met before
you and then you write a note for for
the next stranger I approach once you
read your note you can choose to read it
out loud or keep it to yourself here is
your note oh okay all right this is
exciting
I'm scared hi this is weird this is
weird
I'm not really sure what to write
dot dot dot I guess I'll just share
something random I'm currently reading a
book called shoe dog mm-hmm it's about
the guy who started Nike I can't stop
thinking about this one quote from the
book the single easiest way to find out
how you feel about someone say goodbye
it makes absolutely no sense to me
so what if you say goodbye to someone
and realize you love them
what do you do then you just said
goodbye to them you just said goodbye to
them what do you think of that quote to
me it totally kind of makes sense
because we get really complacent with
the things that our our hours so if you
say goodbye and you leave something then
maybe you'll realize that you
and you'll keep it so my note can say
anything yeah although we're made to
believe otherwise you are worth far more
than we are led to believe
if you're not living on the edge or not
do you
every day when I'm walking down the
street everybody that I meet has a
different point of view and I say hey
it's a wonderful kind of day
PS it's true you are more than your
experiences and what people say you are
so loved
there is more to life than just tourist
comfort kills some guy in a nice suit
with a good paycheck told me that told
me that how do I say follow your dreams
in a way that sounds less lame with all
due respect q I love you punk is a way
of life a rock is something you throw
through the window of a cop car
[Music]
there are no strangers chance is but a
name for law not recognized disconnect
to reconnect if you don't have faith
what is it all for
is it love freely that's so eloquently
put I totally agree with it by the way
one way to happiness is
to be industrious real at these people
are after busy absolutely nothing right
I travel
[Music]
it says how are you feeling today I want
you to know that you are important you
are the light in this world go shine
your light well I'm feeling today better
about this odd interaction
[Music]
it's nice when someone just asked you
how you're doing say
the important thing and that you're a
light in this world is just it's very
nice to hear definitely it it's going to
change my day and a positive participate
for sure
hello first of all I hope you are having
a great day today if nothing else I want
you to know how much you matter and
everyone that comes across you is very
lucky that you have crossed their path
you are amazing and you're more than
words can say sending good vibes your
way always friend take care be safe
much love hello I just want to say that
you are amazing and that you have to be
happy no matter what but hey these ones
are only words for you what is happiness
you rock cool what is happiness
[Music]
feeling like I'm doing some good in the
world this is an interesting project I
wish you all the best in the Rose
remember the love yourself as others
love you and remember it the golden
rules do your next person does that
sound good dear friend yeah yeah yeah
dear friend we wish you all the best
enjoy this beautiful day in Balboa Park
remember to live life to the fullest and
ask yourself this am I truly happy
Wow can you answer the question as well
I think I'm getting there yeah hi there
I hope you're enjoying this beautiful
place here in San Diego
I wonder what brought you here I was
bored and alone at home with my dog
penny when I thought I need to get some
fresh air how lucky am I to live in this
amazing city and get to experience the
beauty of it everyday enjoy the people
the sights the sound and the breeze have
a wonderful day and remember to do
something special for yourself today
when's the last time you took the time
to put yourself first I tried to do it
with little things a little more each
day hello stranger I hope you're
enjoying this lovely afternoon smiles
from a traveler it's a new experience
here on the other coast warm wishes from
your Manor
happy Halloween what is the craziest
costume you have seen in your lifetime
do you remember from a local native you
may or may not know I don't know I'm
just gonna say the fruit of the Loom guy
that balloons all over him how awesome
is Balboa Park
we just smelled a flower called the
sweet sherry which is the most beautiful
orchid smell I've ever smelled in my
life so we think it's pretty amazing and
we also really had a great time seeing
the Mexican artist in the photography
exhibition so we're from Utah so it was
really nice to have diverse voices shown
in the gallery space what made today's
special I'm here from Seattle and I'm
visiting my best friend and he and I are
celebrating 11 years of friendship what
are you doing for self-care today
I'm here if you do another perk I am
missing someone today and that okay I
want to comment okay yeah I think that
it's a bit sad but also so powerful
because it's say like okay I'm I'm a bit
sad because I'm missing someone but it's
okay and sometimes it's like life
happens and it's okay to be sad one day
and maybe get a bit crazy and move
forward the big day
[Music]
sometimes I think the more I see the
less I know do you agree I turn exchange
yes why would you say that I think every
day you have the potential to learn
something new I mean just like these
pages some are complete some are yours
have blank pages where you can learn
more
no more clearance loom from the up
Hospital do not fear price price to move
forward we will breathe I totally agree
remembering that you are going to die is
best way I know to avoid thinking you
have something to lose you are already
naked there is no reason not to follow
your heart attributed to Steve Jobs I
think that sometimes the world is so
complex and noisy if I lose myself how
can I find myself again in these
situations Wow
remember where you come from remember
what's most important to you and have
faith in yourself that's something that
I've really learned myself over the last
six months to a year so that's the best
answer that I have
and be kind to me
[Music]
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
[Music]